mrs hayes was my teacher but then she
humbled herself now
i became your teacher right you became
my teacher yes
about in property since then you came to
the crash course
very first very first crash course
bought four houses
you've got full-time income from
property yes and uh
i have to ask why isn't this taught in
school great to have you
on youtube channel and you've come all
the way from birmingham
the reason i wanted to get you on the
channel debbie is be or shall i say mrs
haye smith you can call me whatever you
want
okay mrs hay smith is because you're my
school teacher i was yeah you taught me
maths
you taught me i.t you taught me to type
yes i did and
um and really got me started in life you
were one of the only school teachers
that actually didn't think i was a
complete
um i don't know whatever you want to
call it and i think my husband also
taught you
he did he did um he did taught me
history
um but honestly really grateful to have
you here
you've now since come out to uh
the crash course yes i've been on a few
crash courses but you came to the very
first crash course i ever ran
i did that's right and let me become
your teacher
yes that's correct and they've gone out
and done crazy things you've bought four
houses
yes hmos joint ventures uh been to
africa with me helped me dig wells in
uganda yeah that was great so i just
knew he's awesome i just needed to hear
the story
and find out like what's what what's
happening oh
well yes i can remember you when you
were sort of knee-high to a grasshopper
some when you came to school with your
brother and sister and your lovely mum
was a teaching assistant in my class
and i saw you grow up with some
some ups and downs throughout your
school
life most mostly ups or downs oh i think
it sort of evened itself out
at the end yeah and
yes um i wouldn't say you were the star
pupil but
was i was what's the opposite of star
was i the uh i
i was kind of i was kind of a bit of a
um what how would you describe middle
school english wasn't my subject
yeah it was maths so
then you started something called
training kings
that was way later though right after i
finished school that was
a long time after you finished school
yeah so there was a long gap when i
had no contact already with you at all
no but at school i just have to put this
out there
you used to um used to
basically i remember you actually saying
to the other pupils
you were like one day your you guys will
be saying
i used to go to school with him that's
what you said did i
yeah i don't remember that you did i can
remember teaching you typing and i think
that's why
you also used to pray over me and
prophesy over me yes
i can remember once in the um typing
suite or
the i.t suite you had
been given the task of writing about a
biblical character
yeah and you chose samuel of course and
you did this
um it was teaching about clip art so
you're putting clip art into
some um writing about some
and you did this enormous ear yeah and
it was really really big and you
you quoted something in the bible saying
you know god i'm listening
yeah and it was up on the wall
for more than a year probably two years
or something
because i thought you as a person didn't
seem to be listening to god
[Laughter]
so i thought well keep it up on the wall
and then one day you were sitting in
front of it typing away with your ten
fingers and
i just got the word evangelist
yeah and i thought that is your calling
is to be an evangelist
and that was that was it really i didn't
think anything more about it
but i feel that now you are an
evangelist probably not the conventional
way
but in a different way through property
yeah would you agree
yeah i would agree yeah yes yeah they
call me the financial advan
evangelist do they yeah i never knew
that yeah yeah
and and of course i'm very um you know
i'm although i teach property
you know i'm very very vocal about faith
and the meaning to life and the fact
there's deeper things
um just in all that i do so yeah
so what did you see in me that what did
you see me when i was a kid when you
said i didn't seem like the kind of i
mean listen i was on the verge of being
expelled i was suspended regularly
i had the most detentions than probably
anyone in the school apart from
one other person who i won't name um
what what what did you see in me that
was
not just bad what did you see in me that
was good i think it wasn't anything
specific which i saw in you yeah what it
was i think it was from my own
school experiences where i used to
perhaps play around a lot and
i used to get comments on my school
reports
which i didn't really find very helpful
and i thought i will never ever want to
be a teacher
who gives negativity out to the children
i want to be always positive
give them encourage them um see what
they've
you know what worth they've got because
i believe everybody's got to give
god-given skill
and sometimes you can't always see that
in in a child
um and sometimes it's something which
you know develops within a person but i
believe everybody
has a skill in life and as a gifting you
know they're good at something
and that may be hospitality it may be
something on the academic
maybe it's sad maybe a doctor
for you you were very um very good at
communicating
you know sometimes in a good way and
sometimes in perhaps
not the best way but that was one of
your giftings
and i think that comes through now when
you've joined the property crash courses
yeah
um you you've got quite a
you're quite quick at thinking on your
feet as well which
um that's something which i think has
come about yeah
i mean school was challenging for me i
left school 16
and as you say i then got into property
um
and then later when i was maybe 22
23 set up training kings and that's when
we reconnected
yes you it was funny because i remember
you gave me a phone call and you said
you thought it'd be great to have some
business networking
group yeah and i'd had the same sort of
thought about
having a business knitting networking
group just really for women
but because i used to be president of
women's glow which is christian
organization in birmingham
however i did nothing with my thoughts
as it were
and then you told me that you'd actually
decided to start this
thing called training kings which was
for you know christians in business
and you started having these meetings
which i
started going to on a regular basis and
ended it for a while hosting the
birmingham yeah training kings
yeah which was you know it was really
enjoyable the only thing i didn't like
about it was the early mornings
yeah it was uh i'm not a morning person
but it was good
there was some great people we met and
you know
we've kept in touch with and that is
where
i feel that you you started
to develop as a person who is very
outgoing and
very confident and
you know the skills which god's
obviously given you were being developed
yeah because prior to training kings i
was just doing property and business and
but that was the first time i opened it
up and started teaching people yes
after i finished bible college yeah so
we we stopped running training kings
you're one of the leaders
uh you then came out to africa yes i
came up with my husband and
your wife um amanda and there were a
couple of other people who came out
um and we went to boar
a well really yeah for children and a
village
and it was very exciting to see the
children all
we gave them cups for them to get the
water in and we
saw the boar machine come and start
boring yeah and
and you were pretty um helpful at
rushing the builders along
and because actually the week after we
left when the
water when the water came up but we were
there while the builders were
on they were digging we hit a dry
borehole to begin with yes uh you went
to vic falls
uh was that your first time in zambia or
was it you're saying in africa
it wasn't my first time in africa i went
on interrail and crossed over from
spain to morocco when i was about 17
yeah so i've been there for about
one night okay um and then i'd gone when
i was a student
with um abigail or daughter
to tunisia yeah um husband also came
out um to look after abigail that was
when i was studying
we were both studying tourism business
management then
and then that must be my third time yeah
in africa
our first time out of north africa yes
yes first time out of north africa
yes it was it was a great experience i
loved it i really really loved it
yeah um yeah so after that
you came to the very first and this is
one of the things i really appreciate
about you you
the very first training kings event in
january 2014
yeah you were the very first one i know
because i made you give me a testimonial
right
yes you were the very first property
investors crash course i ever ran
yeah so there already a few people there
was like six seven people
yes and you were sat with jl spooner
right who's now got a million pound
property business really i'll have to
look at the video again
it's on youtube it's on youtube so you
were the very first
so i really appreciate the fact that
you've just been there at the foot you
were you know the first
um you know training king's the first
crash course you came out to africa with
me before my charity was registered just
at the early stages
of when we were doing the whole
boreholes and wells and things like that
which which is great
you came to the crash course how was the
property investors crash course
well i i really enjoyed it i thought it
was absolutely fantastic it was
something and not
i don't think it even thought about
investing in property or
thinking about property really
but i just inherited some money from
um my motherhood deceased uh
you know fairly recently and so it was a
way of
thinking you know what to do with this
money yeah
because i've never really had much money
um
and yeah so i think that's what really
started
me on the journey but one thing i would
say is that you know being
one of these first meetings because one
thing i feel that
one of my giftings is is to encourage
people so i can encourage people
in what they do i'm not very good as a
leader but as second in command
and being behind the first person behind
being behind the leader
i'm very good at yeah you know blow my
own trumpet here but not at all
i'll vouch for that you're a massive
even when i was at school when i was a
little
uh hooligan at school getting into all
the time
you know you were believing in me then
and then every time i've ever done
something a new initiative
you know i started a new business you
you're you're you're the kind of person
even though i've not seen you in a
couple years
because life and i've moved to beckham's
field and stuff
you know i know if i was in prison you'd
be one of the
10 people if i had to phone someone to
come get me out you'd be one of the
people i'd call
right okay not that i'll be in prison
but no no but that kind of a person
really so
um so you came to the crash course
there's about six or seven people there
or so
yes and you learned all the different
strategies what happened then because
and also just just a little bit before
the crash course
just to understand the story you had
done a little bit of property because
did you not inherit your mother's
house and you've done something with
that to release some funds from it is
that correct
yes well what happened when my mother
died we had a big
property in yorkshire and
some family members members loaned a
builder to
finance the building of other houses
on the land because the house was
an old house it was quite a dilapidated
state
and you will know very well that if you
do up a house you've got vat to pay on
it
and if you knock it down and build new
houses there isn't the vat so that was
one of the
things and also um in the thinking
we just thought it was better to build
three houses in the end on this land
knocked down the old house and built
three
you know really good five-bedroom
houses which were out in the country and
yeah you know
could be for professional people and so
that's what we did and that's how
we sold those on you know paid back the
loan to the family member
and uh yes and i
kind of got you started yes that got me
started
and the first house i
was very interesting because the one
thing i
think i got from the very first property
course was
buy at a reduced rate try and buy
below what they're actually asking for
so
i'd actually made an appointment to see
a house in bangor north wales with my
daughter who was actually in your class
at school yeah even though she's a
different age
yeah the class is mixed quite a bit
isn't there
um she was at university there
and i made an appointment see a house
within the stage agent but that fell
through because they wanted to change
the timing of it
and it was on the day of our daughter's
graduation
however after the graduation i was
walking on the high street and just
looking at some of the shops
so another estate agent and it said
house
which would make a great investment and
i thought oh investment that was the
word really which sort of sprung out of
me
so i went in inquired about this house
went to look at
it remembered what you'd said about
you know lowering asking for a lower
price is it
i didn't say anything at the time i just
looked around the house and
saying oh this would this i think this
would be great house of students
wouldn't you
and the lady was speaking to judy being
a student she just left university over
a year ago so she didn't really know
she knew very little and i knew nothing
you know hardly anything
and i went
um looking at the house went home
and i thought actually you know this
it's a two bedroom house but i could
make it into three bedroom and it's
it's a good location it's within walking
distance of the station it's in the
walking distance of the university
and i could perhaps get it do it up as
an hmo
okay how do you turn a a sitting room
into a bedroom
a sitting room into a bedroom um well
this was downstairs i just
put a bed in it yes
that's right yeah what else do you do um
so and again that was
um a legacy from my husband's parents
because they just passed on so
you know there was some and there were
new new beds um all fireproof and
everything
so that was sort of started so i started
me off however
um when i went home
i thought i'm going to put an offer in
which
i did what was that what was it on the
on the market for
it was on for i think hundred and ten
thousand yeah
and i offered at first
i thought i'd go really what i thought
was ridiculously low to about 80 000
yeah and i got a phone call back saying
no the vendor won't accept that
so um but he would accept 95 000.
so i thought 95 is less than 110.
you know being a must expand teacher so
i thought
well i could accept that so i said yes
and then
of course i didn't live in north wales
because we talked about bangalore in
north wales and
i thought i've got to find a builder
i've got to you know what do i do next
and i didn't actually come back to you
or ask you you know what i should do i
just
got in touch with the estate agents that
you know builder and they referred me to
a builder who was excellent
somebody called carl ryan and he um
he really did the whole house up putting
gas put in um
you know new walls fire doors smoke
alarms all this
you know central heating double glazing
and really didn't cost very much well
you're pretty good at getting things
done cheap
yes i always believe we need to pay full
price for anything
how much did you how much was the full
refurb
i reckon i didn't pay more than about
five thousand so all in you're talking a
hundred thousand pounds
yes and then you rented it out as a hmo
yeah so we're getting over a
thousand pounds without a month and was
that three students
and over a thousand a month was that um
was that profit or was that is that that
was net
oh wow net profit yes okay and
you then refinanced the house yes and
you how much did it get valued at
it got followed 130 000 oh yes yes
and then you pulled out all of your
money bar
was it about five or ten grand yes you
left the end yeah i left
so that's a brr deal right there i left
about 40 000
or something like that oh see so you
pushed the vote by
30 000 pounds it took about about 90 000
but it took out it in two lots
okay i took out one lot to um
ensure that my our only daughter had a
fantastic wedding
i wanted to make a great day of that so
we had a
you know i believe she had a wonderful
husband had a wonderful wedding
um they'll tell me later and then what
about the other 45 grand
and then the other was to buy a new
another house
and where was that that's in stockton on
teas how much do you pay for that house
that was seventy thousand i put in
twenty five thousand
for that and how much you renting that
one out for is that a hmo or a single
letter um
that's single let there's a family with
three children and a dog
and it's um that's about
5.75 okay a month so pretty good return
on investment yes
and um but in between times i bought a
couple of other houses
yeah um that was very interesting
i don't know really quite how it
happened in a way i was um
i was collecting a car from my sister's
house in sheffield
and i got a phone call from some
landlord
there are some estate agents are saying
that there were
there was a house that was to view
oh no the phone call had come before
that say there's a house a good
view which was had tenants in
and it had been divided into two flats
and both the flats were tenanted so i
thought
well i'm going up to sheffield on such
and such a day i'll go and look at this
these two flats which is you know
upstairs and downstairs basically
anyway i was driving up they said the
tenants weren't available for me to see
the house
so i thought oh well no great deal and
then
within minutes they'd run again saying
we've got a couple of houses you may be
interested in
so i thought um well i'd go and see them
and i asked as i was picking this car
from my sister
i said to her would you be interested in
you know doing a joint venture with me
and
she was like oh i don't want to get
involved in property i don't want to get
involved in property
so i went with her though to view the
houses
and there was one which was a two
bedroom one was one bedroom
and when we'd come away they were both
really nicely furnished well not
furnished but nicely decorated there's
no front should have them
um she said oh i think i would like to
share you know do a job adventure with
you no i'm one of them
and so that's what that's what we did
as a teacher yes why don't they teach
this in schools why don't they teach
joint ventures and
property investing and money well i
think they've got
i really the school curriculum now i
think should be radically changed i mean
if you
if you ask me about it i would write a
completely new curriculum
i think a lot of it is just a total
waste of time it doesn't
actually give the children the what they
need in life
and i think that's what schooling should
be about it should be giving them the
financial education i think that's so
important it's like
it's like when i was i was i mean we
were blessed we were in a
school where i was able to for example
teach people to type with 10 fingers
because why go to school and learn to
write with a pencil
when it was the day when people were
using were typing
yeah and i can say that
i've had people from ex-pupils who
actually
one girl worked in lloyd's and she was
given some reward for her typing
skills and
it was really only because
she was taught to type with 10 fingers a
lot of things like typing are not taught
in school
you know it's a fundamental thing i mean
now maybe not so much but
you know you should be able to use the
mobile phone with you know maybe i don't
know we
both your members i mean most a lot of
children can but
i don't know how to use a mobile phone
most effectively yeah no that's true but
when
people come when when people come for a
job interview
with me and my business we care about
things like
how fast they can tie yes i could type
fast cause you taught me
we care about things like how well they
can communicate yes we care about things
like how well they can
manage money depending on of course what
the job is but a lot of the stuff you
learn in school
it's it's it's to pass an exam yes to
then be able to show oh i got an a
yes but actually when i'm interviewing
people i don't care if they got an a
no i didn't get any a's yeah i got b
top yeah so so i'm interested in their
skills not their qualifications yes
yes and i i agree i think that the whole
curriculum is looking at
as you know you've helped me with my
africa work we are um
we went last time i was in uganda last
year we negotiated with the ugandan
government
to build a school and i said look i'll
pay for the school
yes i'll pay for the school we'll build
the school as long as you let me come in
and teach money
as long as i can be a little bit
involved in the curriculum even if it's
extracurricular yes yes
you know because i think it's just basic
why teach kids how to get how to get
good
good grades to get a job to then get
money yes why not just teach them about
money and
and skip skip a lot of the other stuff
and how to also generate
um residual income income which will
just come in whether you're working or
not you know just sleeping so
um you know things like property is
great for that
well that's what you've got now from
property oh yes i mean i was made
redundant
yeah so you know
now i can live off my rental income
yeah i have to live off my original
income and that is my
that is my income because believe it or
not i'm not old enough to be a pension
because i keep
changing the age you know i should have
been retired
but they changed the age yeah then they
put it up another year
and then another year and then another
year and then another year
and then another year so they put it up
yeah
i still haven't reached that age yeah so
i'm not up to the pension of bullet age
my daughter's just been told her
pensionable age is going to be when
she's 75
well who wants to be working as whatever
doctor nurse
you know clean or whatever to the age of
75 some jobs you can't physically
really do when you you know that's
that's that
that's crazy so what what would you have
done when you were made redundant
if you didn't have your rental income
well i suppose the first thing i'd have
done would have
i would have signed on got on what is
now universal credit
yeah and i may have applied for some
teaching jobs but then
i may because of the competition um
or you know i may not have got a job and
i may
just then have resigned myself to oh
well i'll have to be on universal credit
for the next
you know 10 years or whatever and and
you just go down
you know a spiral hole because there's
nothing to really motivate you
um but you know so this
property having property is you know
really
it's been great i love it i love it you
love being a property investor
yeah yeah i love it and you know i want
to help other people be um
invest in property you know so if
there's anybody out there who wants some
help
you know but the thing is that you want
to help other people
and encourage people yes because that's
your heart that's what you're about
you're about doing it but also i mean
right now you're also working with
um you've got a little um venture going
on in birmingham
yes tell me about that well i um
i suppose when when i was getting the
property and everything and i had
my extra time i decided to get an
allotment
um i've never been much of a gardener
but anyway something i
i think had gone in and just put my name
down there was a show on something put
my name down and
not thought anything about it three
years later it came up and said you
still want this allotment
so i decided i would have an allotment
and i met a lady there
who had a property which she'd reached
out
very successfully for 20 years and then
she'd rent
the lady she'd rented it out to died and
then his son
took it over and um it got in a bit of a
state he moved out
and then it was um
she saw a builder doing some work on a
house
next door to this property and i think
she wanted something like a drain pipe
put him so he put in a drain pipe for
her
and then he said he would could do the
property
but basically he just filled it with all
his rubbish and
lots of stuff which i think probably
took to car boot sales and
it was just full of absolute junk and
she told me about this
and i didn't really think about it
for a property sense or business sense
or anything like that
but one day she said you want to come
and see my property
so i said yes i would when i saw it i
was absolutely horrified because
the state of the house the floorboards
were up there were wires here there and
everywhere there was plaster of the
walls
i mean the plasterboard this
person had tried to build a shower
but the plasterboard was put on back to
front so you couldn't even
have plastered a plastic board so
i just told you you've got to get you
know you've got to move this person out
and i'll get you a
proper builder in and that's what i've
done he was like a squatter
yes he wasn't actually living there it
was all it was it was squatting with all
his things
so he's pretending to be a builder yeah
but he was just had his
junk there he didn't seem to know really
oh my goodness
and this lady as well how old was she
she's 74. so she's 74.
owns this house next month she's getting
a builder to come out the builder's
really just using it to store his junk
leaving her up the garden path not doing
anything and then
and then and then you this poor lady
reaches out to you yeah
and now what's happening well she didn't
when i said she reached out to me she
just
i think she knew you know i had property
and she thought
she'd show me the property i don't think
she was expecting me to actually do
anything but i couldn't let
i couldn't let her go on in her life
having a house which i did i did some
research
and i felt the value of it in the
present condition was
at an auction would probably go for
forty thousand
yeah um but i looked at the houses in
the area another
you know did other due diligence and i
reckon the house would be
worth at least 130 000 maybe so you're
thinking
there's at least 90 000 pounds uplift
here yes
and how much is it going to cost to do
it up yes well i thought it probably
cost about 30
000 yeah that was just a very rough
estimate
um and i got a couple of quotes
from from builders and one of them
showed me properties he'd done up
already and i was very impressed with
the standard of his work
yeah and that sort of swung me towards
one particular builder
and the cost is just going to be just
under fifty thousand
okay but that is um it's a new it's a
completely new
shower unit um a couple of toilets
bathroom
kitchen uh three three bedrooms
lounge the garden as um
all this um so it's got to be taken
right back to the walls
yeah you know so it's a complete
refill all the windows but then what i
remember saying to you
my suggestion would be you project
manage it
and then go 50 50 on the uplift yes but
you were like you know what i just want
to do this as a favor so you're
basically
you are charging a small amount yeah but
really you're doing that just because
you want to you want to help this lady
right
well i was just doing it really just to
help her i wasn't asking for anything
and then she said
i'd like to pay something so i didn't
really know what to say because i'd
never done
anything specifically like before
anyway she offered me some certain
amount of money that she would
give me as a gift really yeah which
which you know i was happy to accept
yeah because do you think do you think
in business
to get you because you're you're a good
negotiator you're good at getting things
why don't i remember telling you at the
crash course
if you're not embarrassed about the
price it's too high yes
so always always offer low um do you
think
but you're a very soft caring kind
person so how do you fit
that kind of hardcore getting a good
deal approach
combined with caring loving
kind do the two go hand in hand or not
well it was funny because this person
who put all his
materials and things in the house yeah i
spoke to him
really straight on i had to sort of say
you were hard with him i was and the and
the
the ladies who asked it was she said you
know um
i think you because i asked for he
changed the locks on the house as well
so
i was asking for the keys back and you
know and
asked him to take everything out within
a few days and
you know the lady was saying i think
you're a bit you know you're a bit hard
on him
and i said you've got to be cruel to be
kind yeah so sometimes
you know it needs somebody to be a
straight talker
yeah and you know or come from yorkshire
where they're taught straight
yeah so you know um i can be very
straight
some people sometimes take them the
wrong way but that's
that's how i am you know you can't
change who you are
yeah yeah and you a bit like me
you were very um you you've had you've
offended people even teachers are in the
school
and things like that i don't want to go
don't want to go there
in too much detail but you even even
recently you know you have people
sometimes
um unfriending you on facebook because
they think you're too outspoken or
you're too
you know and i think i can relate to
that similarly because i seem to cause a
bit of controversy
what did you think when you saw because
you know me very well you know since i
was a little kid yes
when you saw all the stuff all over the
media you know this samuel leads hard
pressure selling people and this
what did you think when you saw that
well one of the things i've learned in
life
is that bad publicity
is also publicity and it's free
publicity
and it hurts it hurts just bad publicity
you know you can be the most successful
person
but still get this bad publicity and you
know we're all human and
it and it does hurt um but you just have
to go to get on with life and you've got
to look at the positives in life you've
got to look at
the things that you know you've got to
be true to yourself know what you're
doing is
what you you know what you believe to be
truthful and right and to go with it
and the media just unfortunately in this
day and age
it's not like where there were gentlemen
and you know
they would act to build people up
they i think we have a very much in this
car in this country
um a culture where you'll build somebody
up
and when they're up get up to the top or
the near you know successful they'll
tear them down
i mean we saw that with people like
princess donna we've seen it with
megan markle recently you know um people
will you know be
you know successful in what they do but
the british tend to always seem to like
to
pull them down and and and kick them and
you know not literally you know but
um yeah i think we have probably a very
bad
media and it's changed a lot
unfortunately you know the bbc was built
on christian principles but
those principles have just gone out of
the you know out of the window
yeah um so and it's the same with
with uh schools you know um a lot of the
christian principles
even that the you know whole country has
been built on
um people just disregard yeah
so yeah no i think you're right and i
was very fortunate to
um you know to go to have a christian
family and go to
go to a christian school with good
values and um
have good people that you know believed
me and
taught and taught me well growing up
what did you think when you came back
the second time to the crash course
because the first time you were there
there was
like seven people maybe how many was
there when you came the second time
there must have been a thousand
people what did you think when you came
in it's like oh my goodness there's a
thousand people here
oh it was just amazing really because i
don't think i've ever been to
any free course i mean it's free
um why there have been so many people
and so many people are so enthusiastic
and who worked i mean what i liked about
the property course
really from the word go from the very
first one up to the time when there were
a thousand people
you got people working together into
small teams and
networking together you know even if
they didn't know each other and
they've been so many people on the
property courses who've come out
and i keep hearing oh you know i've just
spent
uh oh i've just either got a property
portfolio worth
a million pounds and you know in four or
five years and
and i'm thinking wow you know and
you know it's just amazing really what
your teaching has done
yeah so you know it's the is that is the
teaching of
um you know how to do various strategies
which are all taught in a sort of basic
level of the property course and if
people want to do more i know they can
do further advancement yeah exactly it's
their choice really whether they do
yeah but that you did the free course
yes and
and you haven't paid me any money for
training no i haven't
and all of your property stuff has been
just from the crash course is that right
um well more or less so yes i mean you
know i mean
all the knowledge that i've got has been
from the from the property courses
i did go on another property three-day
course where i did learn
a little bit more
and you know i'll be
learning some more you know about i
wanted to learn more
from as anybody really
you know but obviously i like to learn
from yourself because you were about
beautiful
yeah so um yeah it's uh
and we've had dinner just now what's
next we've been talking about what
you're gonna be doing next in property
what's the plan what are the plans well
i mean to
i've been looking over the last few
weeks i've been looking at deal sourcing
yeah um because i think
i'm quite good at getting good deals on
properties
and getting quite high income
you know rentals from property
but but fair rentals you know tennis
paying for
fair rentals um so
i would like to help other people you
know get properties
where they could become financially free
yeah they can
you know i'm hoping that my daughter and
son-in-law that they will
you know eventually get some properties
of their own
yeah you know so they have an extra
extra income you know and anybody who
really wants an extreme income is that
and the other thing i'm very interested
in is serviced accommodation
oh yeah i think that is
something i would like to do
in birmingham because the properties at
the moment none of them are in
birmingham
um and i just think birmingham is an up
and coming place
for you know young professionals and
also
for people who just want to come for
short breaks yeah i think it's um
you know destination where a lot of
people don't go to i mean i never
i never wanted to go to birmingham never
wanted to live in birmingham
um never visited birmingham really
because it was just a
no-go area and i think it's still cost
is
that really it's got to it's got a very
bad reputation with outside birmingham
that's what i feel anyway
um and then
if people have come to birmingham there
are a lot of people who like
just to come for short breaks because
there's a lot going on yeah for sure the
commonwealth games coming
that's an ideal opportunity yeah for
people too
what would be your advice for anyone
watching this who's maybe a teacher
or maybe you know i've
been in a situation like you where you
think actually i don't know loads about
property but i really want to get some
income because i don't want to retire at
75
relying on a pension what will be your
advice and tips
from all you've learned over the last
however many years in property well i
think the first
thing is that you've got to self-educate
you've got to
you know you've got to be open to change
yeah
i was forced into change because i was
made redundant i mean otherwise it might
have been a whole different story i
don't know
i really don't know um and i was you
know blessed to be able to have
some um you know an inheritance
the redundancy money was really next to
nothing because i've been
on a minimum wage so um
but if you have got no money then
you know i know that there are
strategies to get involved
with no or very little money um
and really it's just to
you know think about think about your
future really especially if you're young
yeah you know where are you going to get
that money from if your
pension age is 75 and even though you
might be paying to a pension now
company pension is it going to pay out
because a lot of company pensions
haven't been paying out as they should
yeah some people are having to you know
you know live like paupers really yeah
in their old age so
um i think having residual income
it doesn't necessarily have to be from
property but i think property could be
one of the ways
you can get residual income yeah and
also if even if you inherit
if you even if you inherit some money
yeah if you inherit some money but then
you live off it
it's going to shrink and turn to nothing
absolutely but if you invest it into
something that's going to give you an
income
yes then it's then it's forever then yes
i mean especially now you know if i put
that money in the bank
what's the interest naught point one
percent or something
and i mean my income is you know i can
get returns of 10 plus you know which
and on top of it you've got an
appreciating asset absolutely so you've
got
bricks and mortar which is probably
going to go up in value yes
because there's only limited whether
it's cash they're printing it and it's
giving you
rent which you can live off yes so it's
a complete no-brainer yeah no it's a
win-win situation
um yeah i mean traditionally i mean
some people say property doubles every
seven years i like to say it doubles
every 10 years
and that you know that doesn't mean it
just goes up up up it can
go down and up it's up and down up and
down but if you look at the cost of
houses generally speaking
you know every 10 years that property
has
doubled in in price which is you know
usually more than the
rate of inflation yeah i mean especially
if you buy in the right area
yeah which you've done because your
properties are all going up pretty
nicely
yes so now that's great well thank you
for coming on
the channel and encouraging people and
sharing your story i hope i have
encouraged people it's been um
it's been a long day so you know yeah
you've been at my house for the last
several hours in the evening no i think
you would have done and
i tell you one thing though you've
definitely encouraged me
not just today but for the last 20 odd
years
which has given me strength to go and
encourage millions of people
my youtube channels have millions of
views thank you so thank you thanks for
encouraging me well thank you so
yeah all right welcome nice to see the
way you've developed and
grow up with it and having spent some
time with your lovely family today
yeah you met my kids for the first time
today yes and they loved you it was
lovely it was lovely to see you i'd like
to spend more time with them you will do
so guys i hope you enjoyed hearing from
mrs hay smith you want to get in touch
with her
i'll leave her details in the
description below if you want to see
more interviews because i
interview someone every single week
that's becoming financially free in
property
as a direct result of my training then
you can check out a whole list of
interviews up right here if you want to
watch a more content packed video that's
going to help you in your journey check
out this video right here
and please subscribe for more videos
down here below
thanks so much i appreciate you i'll see
you next time